we should really have the office's air
quality tested and we have radon coming
from below we have aestus in the
ceilings these are silent Killers you
are the silent killer go back to the NX
you'll see times have changed a
little and even though we're still a
family here at Dunder Mifflin families
grow and at some point the daddy can't
take a bath with the kids
anymore I am upper management and it
would be inappropriate for me to take
take a bath with Pam as much as I might
want to he said what come on Michael
you're you're interrupting you're
kidding me God you say Ron is silent but
deadly and then you expect me not to
make farting noises with my mouth what
is this sit down you know what we're not
going to die of raon we're going to die
of borom yeah right and if I had a gun
with two bullets and I was in a room
with Hitler Bin Laden and Toby I would
shoot Toby
twice okay being really funny and then
you went too far all right girls bring
it up you're being infiltrated in
the hen house in the hen house
don't say
oh uh what is your name aair
lass Katie ah Katie wow look at you you
are uh you're like the new and improved
pam pam
6.0 oh look oh hey no cat fights you two
I'm against violence in the workplace so
am I and nobody cares what you doesn't
matter i a great summer I got West n
virus lost a ton of weight then I went
back to the lake hey stepped on a piece
of glass in the parking lot which hurt
that got infected even though I peed on
it saw
Inception or at least I dreamt I
did Michael how can you appreciate women
so much but also dump one of
them you mean how can I be so illogical
and flighty and unpredictable and
emotional well maybe I learn something
from women after
all nothing much what's up with you I
cannot believe I fell for that oh my
God what what where's the
funny give it to
me um was it me or does it smell like up
dog in here what's up dog nothing much
what's up with you
oh wow I walked right into that oh
that's
brilliant hey sanley is that jacket made
of up dog I'm on the phone and
we what flavor coffee is that up dog
what's that I don't know nothing what's
up with
you huh no damn it what does that mean
what does what mean the thing you just
said let's forget it
Dwight hey is it me or does this place
smell like up dog what's up dog
[Laughter]
Goa
crap nothing how are you doing good how
are you
doing Toby why don't you open your
present no no no no no no no this hey
hey hey hey this might not be what I
think that I don't even know is in there
because there are a lot of presents in
my car and I don't know which is
which suck on
this what the hell is that Michael
that's what do you mean
Michael that's not even my handwriting
hey what the hell is going on here who
thought it would be hysterical to give
Toby a rock for his going away gift you
did no you made me rap it I thought it
was over the line I
just attention everyone hello uh yes I
just want you to know that uh this is
not my decision but from here on out we
can no longer be
friends and when we talk about things
here we must only discuss uh work
Associated things and uh you can
consider this my retirement from Comedy
and in the future if I want to say
something funny or witty or do an
impression I will no longer ever do any
of those things does that include that's
what she
said mhm yes wow that is really
hard you really think you can go all day
long well you always left me satisfied
and smiling
so that's what she
said Michael Michael please please hey I
I just want to say that I cannot believe
that I walked into a koi pond I mean
seriously walk
much oh I should wear a snorkel to the
next business meeting that I go to
Michael you know when you think about it
it's not all your fault I mean who puts
a in a Lobby well you know what
you're right Phyllis but I've been there
before I've seen that pond this is the
thing I am a world class the
problem please stop it now you're
embarrassing yourself it's okay we're
having fun it's actually not the first
time I've been embarrassed by a
pond in high school the girls volleyball
team always used to throw me into the
frozen lake four years in a
row was freezing no no no oh this is
even worse a couple weeks ago I went to
get a new cell phone and I wanted one of
those packages where you have the five
you know the friends friends and family
thing and the guy was like who are your
five friends and I'm like uh I didn't
even know I couldn't even think oh my
God it was so embarrassing that was who
I don't even have Jan's cell phone
number and I hate her you won't give it
to me I was like oh well I guess I'm a
loser
ier too far
God thanks a lot lot man thanks for the
advice there is such a thing as good
grief this ask Charlie
Brown Ryan wanted Michael the subject to
uh explain the computer system the
object to whomever meaning us the
indirect object which is the the correct
usage of the word no one uh asked you
anything ever so whomever's name is Toby
why don't you take a letter opener and
stick it into your skull hey
spamster
um Pam plus spam plus hamster right
speaking of relationships of all all way
shapes and forms um I was out on a very
very hot date last night with a girl
from HR Dwight really we don't have any
girls from HR no
that for the sake of the story and
things were getting hot and heavy yeah
and uh I was about to take her bra off
when she had fill out 6 hours worth of
paperwork like an AIDS
test
no God there's this guy he at a
nyphomaniac convention and he is psych
cuz all these women are smoking hot
perfect tens except for this one chick
who looks a lot like U fell us no no no
no that crosses the line exqueeze
me not you
Kevin just
unwarranted hostile work environment
Kevin Packer said it no you said it he
pointed a point is not a say look Kevin
we are a family here and Phyllis is a
valued member of that family like a
grandmother I'm the same age as you
Michael I don't know about that we're
the same High School CL well I have a
late birthday and usually September is a
cut off point you know what you just
crossed the line okay there's a line and
you went over it and you must be
punished so go to your corner you mean
where my desk is yes your corner go
okay I have a lot of work to do anyway
oh my they really got to you didn't they
they didn't get to
me I got to
them I am still the same old Michael
Scott new and
improved you know what I love
Phyllis you know what
else I think she is gorgeous I think she
is an incredible inly incredibly
attractive person come here come here
CHR come on Mel come on you don't have
to worry I'm
not I'm not worried HR you know what the
only thing I am worried about is getting
a
boner good work today
everybody so um I Heard a very very
funny joke the other day you want to
hear it Christian you don't you don't
have to listen to this it's okay I like
jokes okay just the one just one joke
okay well if it's just going to be one I
will think of a different joke
um